nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
depuis des décennies les rohinga
minorité musulmane de Birmanie sont la
cible d'exaction organisée par la jante
au pouvoir et des moines bouddhistes
extrémistes des sciences de nationalité
village incendie viol torture en 2017 de
nouveaux massacres perpétrés par l'armée
birmane et qualifiée de génocide vont
pousser plus de 700 000 rohings à fuir
l'espace de quelques semaines vers le
Bangladesh voisin les réfugiés
s'installent dans le district de
coxbazar au sud du Bangladesh mais la
vie y est précaire 5 ans après cet exode
massif le gouvernement bangladais a
décidé de déplacer une partie des
rowing-gas vers un nouveau camp créé de
toutes pièces un constituée sur une île
isolée au large du golfe du Bengale pour
la première fois depuis l'ouverture de
ce nouveau camp les autorités
bangladaises ont autorisé des
journalistes occidentaux à se rendre sur
place
elles vont Alvarez bonjour on vous
retrouve en duplex de New Delhi avec
Mathilde Cusin vous avez pu en
exclusivité accompagnée d'héroïne gars
dans ce nouveau camp sur une île qui
soulève de nombreuses inquiétudes
notamment du Haut Commissariat des
Nations Unies pour les réfugiés
exactement Antoine a fallu plusieurs
mois de négociation pour convaincre les
autorités du Bangladesh de donner
l'accès à bassenshars quand ce projet de
déplacer une partie des réfugiés vers
une île aux larges du Bangladesh a vu le
jour il y a deux ans le gouvernement a
été vivement critiqué par les ONG qui
pointaient notamment en haut du doigt le
risque de voir l'île balayer par des
cyclones et surtout le manque criant
d'infrastructures sur place
alors on va regarder ce reportage
l'éternel exil des rowing-gas un
reportage signé de Mathilde Cusin
lacminage et mine soma et Alban Alvarez
qu'on retrouve juste après
[Musique]
c'est un convoi qui doit les mener vers
une nouvelle vie sur ses bateaux de la
marine Bangladesh 3000 réfugiés
rowing-gas s'apprête à rejoindre une île
aux large du golfe du Bengale
parmi eux achète Arabie gomme 19 ans et
son mari Ousmane
ces jeunes exilés ont fui en 2017 la
Birmanie après des années de répression
[Musique]
s
de vie dans les camps de réfugiés du sud
du pays à chez Tara et Ousmane se sont
portés volontaires pour un nouveau tout
quitter
il s'apprête à rejoindre leurs proches
sur l'île de bassinchar
en plein milieu du golfe du Bengale ces
infrastructures tout juste sorties de
terre forment un nouveau camp pour les
réfugiés rowinga entièrement financé par
le Bangladesh
23000 d'entre eux ils ont déjà été
déplacés
ne savent pas quand ils rentreront en
Birmanie
Bassan sharp pourrait être leur dernière
demeure
[Musique]
cinq ans après le dernier exode de
rohinga vers le Bangladesh le pays n'a
pas encore réussi à négocier leur
rapatriement bassin Charles est devenu
sa nouvelle solution pour gérer ses
déplacés
mais ce con insulaire suscite depuis sa
création de nombreuses interrogations de
la part des ONG
[Musique]
nous sommes la première télévision
occidentale à être autorisée à nous y
rendre depuis l'arrivée de ces réfugiés
lac Minaj et smile soma une journaliste
bangladaises et spécialiste des rohinga
nous a obtenu un laisser passer
mais notre tournage se fera sous
surveillance des autorités
ici les réfugiés se voient attribués par
famille de quatre personnes ces chambres
de 15 mètres carrés
les sanitaires sont communs
[Applaudissements]
a fait partie de ce premier convoi de
déplacer de son plein gré nos dira-t-il
voici ma famille c'est ma femme
le jeune réfugié vit ici avec sa femme
fata
ainsi que leurs trois enfants nés dans
les camps de réfugiés
le Bangladesh n'a pas accordé au rohinga
le droit à la liberté de mouvement ni à
l'éducation ou au travail alors la
famille a appris à vivre ici dans
l'attente
résilier à une vie d'apatride
nous ne savons pas combien de temps nous
restons ici
selon les instructions du gouvernement
actuellement nous sommes des réfugiés et
le Bangladesh nous emmènera où il le
souhaite
pour autant Mounir nos conflits préférés
cette condition à celle qu'il vivait
dans les autres camps de réfugiés du sud
du Bangladesh
il y avait un groupe de gants
et si on ne pouvait pas les payer
c'est pour ça qu'on a déménagé ici
situé à la frontière avec la Birmanie le
district de coxbazar abrite aujourd'hui
le plus grand camp de réfugiés au monde
30 km2
sur lesquels s'entassent plus d'un
million de ringards
les autorités tentent désormais de
désengorger ces lieux où les conditions
de vie ne cesse de se durcir
des gangs de rohinga impliquées dans des
trafics de drogue ils font régner la
terreur
rien qu'en 2021 151 feu ont été
dénombrés
trois jours avant notre venue ici
flammes ont laissé plus de 3000 familles
sans toi
[Musique]
deux enfants ont perdu la vie dont le
fils aîné de chamsida et Mohamed
une psychologue bénévole est venue les
accompagner à travers ce deuil
est-ce que vous pouvez l'emmener au
cimetière ce soir
si vous venez sur la tombe de votre fils
ça pourra l'aider à faire son deuil et
ensuite elle pourra s'alimenter à
nouveau
le jour de l'incendie la famille était
partie chercher des rations
lorsque le feu s'est déclaré leur fils
Ayas pris de panique a couru vers leur
maison il y est resté piégé par les
flammes
il avait quel âge
mon fils
un enfer que de jeunes rohinga tentent
de combattre avec des mots en guise
d'armes
avec toi
font partie d'un collectif de jeunes
poètes qui publie sur leur réseau
sociaux des rimes engagées
ou encore en anglais qu'ils ont appris
dans les camps
en pensant à ce que j'ai subi
mais celui de Messi
parlent de leur persécution aux
ambirmanie
et qui dénonce leur condition de vie à
Cox bazar
in
[Musique]
de la Birmanie au Bangladesh
alors
construire sa vie malgré les
circonstances
avec ces dernières économies il a pu
s'acheter ce vélo qui l'utilise en
triporteur grâce à cette activité il
peut gagner jusqu'à 5 euros par jour
ne veulent pas venir sur Lille
Mounir et les 23000 autres réfugiés sont
libres de circuler sur l'île
mais pour la quitter il leur faut une
autorisation spéciale
aujourd'hui ils vivent donc surtout au
rythme des distributions alimentaires
des lopins de terre leur ont été alloués
pour cultiver
les infrastructures publiques elles sont
peu nombreuses quelques cliniques
privées de ONG et cet hôpital
gouvernemental alors une question se
fait jour
Bassan Charles serait-elle au final
qu'une île prison conçue pour tenir
l'héroïne gaz à l'écart les autorités en
charge de l'île sont défendent bien sûr
que c'est mieux ici
sont en mauvais état les gens doivent
constamment réparer leur cabanes sont
dépendant des ONG pour absolument
les routes
le gouvernement de Bangladesh fait
vraiment de son mieux ici
mais pourquoi leur faut-il une
autorisation spéciale pour retourner sur
le continent c'est connu que quand des
gens fuient un pays
[Musique]
déplacer
d'aider le Bangladesh dont les processus
de rapatrie
en attendant pour affronter les années
et les cyclones propres au golf du
Bengale le gouvernement a fait
construire cette digue tout autour de
bassenchard et aurait dépensé 350
millions d'euros pour garantir des
infrastructures sécurisées
[Musique]
pour espérer mettre un jour un terme à
leur situation d'apatride les réfugiés
eux mis sur l'éducation de leurs enfants
donc maintenant nous devons faire
quelque chose pour que nos enfants
puissent en avoir une meilleure
vie
nous devons donc préparer l'avenir de
nos enfants
ils sont éduqués ont peut-être espérer
trouver de meilleurs emplois et il
pourra leur s'occuper de leur famille
[Musique]
depuis le coup d'État en Birmanie en
2021 les négociations pour rapatrier
l'héroïne gaz sont désormais au point
mort
en attendant le Bangladesh a prévu de
déplacer sur bassin char plus de 100 000
réfugiés
on retrouve notre correspondant dans la
région Alban Alvarez Alban ce voyage
vers cette île ou unten c'est un voyage
sans retour pour l'héroïne gars pour les
réfugiés que nous avons rencontré c'est
d'abord un moyen d'échapper à leur faire
des camps de Cox bazar en attendant un
retour en Birmanie car malgré les
atrocités qu'ils ont subi depuis des
années malgré la jungle militaire au
pouvoir malgré les accusations de
génocide et bien les rowingiens ne
veulent qu'une chose s'est retournée sur
leur terre mais attention ce retour en
Birmanie ne pourra se faire selon eux
qu'avec la garantie d'un retour sécurisé
surtout la garantie de retrouver leur
nationalité dont ils ont été déchus il y
a déjà plusieurs décennies les autorités
bangladaises ne cachent d'ailleurs pas
que l'île de Bassan char doit être une
solution temporaire oui puisque à
l'origine personne devait être une base
militaire et les autorités bangladaises
l'ont transformées bien en camp de
réfugiés ils insistent pour dire que les
conditions les conditions de vie sur
sont meilleurs que dans les camps de Cox
bazar sur le continent mais vous allez
le voir dans cette interview d'un
médecin bangladais que l'accès aux soins
sur l'île reste tout de même limitée
c'est très difficile pour nous de
prendre en charge des cas orthopédiques
ou très urgent
de survie d'un bébé prématuré son faible
car nous ne pouvons pas le prendre en
charge
nous n'avons pas tout le temps accès au
bateau en cas de mauvaise météo nous ne
pouvons pas évacuer un patient vers
l'hôpital sur le continent
voilà nos difficultés
en fait le Bangladesh ce sont
extrêmement seul pour gérer cette crise
humanitaire il y a bien entendu des
dizaines d'ONG sur place et surtout la
présence du Haut Commissariat des
Nations Unies pour les réfugiés mais
cela ne suffit pas les négociations pour
un éventuel rapatriement des réfugiés
sont au point mort avec la Birmanie
Dakar on appelle désormais aux Nations
unies pour faire pression sur leur
Anggun
Alban Alvarez Anu Delhi pour France 24
merci Alban c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]